the first person to kiss Paula Abdul
isn't who you think it is
we are told that according to Paula I
had my first kiss Under a Tree near the
school it was with a boy named Michael
who rarely spoke but he would sometimes
give me one of the cookies from his
lunch maybe it was the gifts that made
me feel special I don't know but when
our lips touched it felt magical but
there were no lips at least not on a guy
named Michael who had cookies the whole
story is made up it's a joke written by
Joe quozzala it was published on
clickhole in 2015 where the joke was
that it sounds like a story from her
youth but it's actually adult Paula
Abdul just talking about her week so far
but the punchline was lost on many and
today if you Google Paula Abdul's first
kiss you will find that that joke has
become consensus history now I looked
into it and Paula Abdul's first kiss
actually came from a man named Craig
Schiller but I'm glad that quiet Michael
a man who was never born and has no lips
is here with us he sounds nice